[Music]
of all the fighting game series that
normally transition from arcades to
consoles Tekken has long been the most
generous with its extra features and in
recent years the goal of unlocking and
customizing outfits for the game's large
cast has rounded out the most rewarding
objective of all getting good Tekken 7
keeps most of the series traditions
alive and once again delivers the tight
hard-hitting action Tekken is known for
though it stumbles a little online and
fails to teach new players how to fight
it's otherwise a great fighting game
that confidently claims its position
among the best fighting games today
similar to dead or alive in Virtua
Fighter Tekken 7 is a 3d fighting game
and thus plays quite differently than
its side-scrolling cousins
there are Tekken 7 characters that are
more mobile than others but by and large
this is a game of inches a moment of
indecision or a sloppy move against a
more skilled player can lead to a string
of pummeling strikes and a hasty death
courtesy of the game is long combo
strings
the biggest complaint you can lob at
tekken 7 is that it doesn't do a good
job of explaining the intricacies of its
mechanics let alone how you should
approach learning your character of
choice move lists often hover around 100
entries serving a mix of one-off special
attacks and combos there's no tutorial
mode to speak of so the best you can do
is hop into training mode and shift from
one move to the next none of this is to
say that Tekken 7 is too deep which
would be a ridiculous complaint the
depth of its roster and fighting styles
is to your benefit the point is that new
players will have very little help
learning anything beyond the basics once
they jump into battle but if this isn't
your first king of Iron Fist tournament
and you've kept up with Tekken over its
more than 20 year tenure you will find
that tekken 7 delivers the same great
combat you know and love with a hefty
batch of new characters and a few new
mechanics there are notable new super
moves that can be triggered when a
player's health is dangerously low which
is also the right time to unleash a rage
drive attack a powered-up standard combo
the most important new addition however
is the power crush attack attribute
relevant attacks can absorb incoming
hits mid animation allowing you to risk
a little health to increase your chances
of landing a critical blow and this
injects Tekken's otherwise familiar
fights with a renewed element of
surprise
but the most conspicuous addition to
Tekken 7 must be aqua ma the red-haired
bad guy of Street Fighter Fame
the introduction of fireballs and
hurricane kicks might seem like an odd
fit for Tekken but they don't feel
overpowered in light of the fact that
every character exhibits unique
advantages in battle Street Fighter fans
will appreciate how easy it is to fight
as Akuma as many of his traditional
moves and inputs are present and
accounted for
even street fighters meter based
mechanics have been carried over for his
Tekken debut more interestingly akima
plays a pivotal role in the main story
hailed as the final chapter in the
series long running tale of martial arts
papa Heihachi Mishima and his quarreling
family Tekken sevens main story will
delight long-standing Tekken fans the
only major downfall here is the robotic
and stale narrator in the darkness a
fellow reporter visited me and offered
me a ray of hope in the form of an
expose on G corporation his delivery is
too shallow to take seriously and yet
not witty enough to make his deadpan
cadence funny beyond the two to three
hours spent on the main story every
character not present there in gets
their own brief chapter limited to a
short text intro a single fight and a
unique ending cutscene not all are
created equal but there are gems to find
that are purposefully awkward and
light-hearted admirers of the alien
samurai yoshimitsu will for example
appreciate how he's initially humanized
and made vulnerable in his story only to
be subsequently needed and growing by
the object of his affection as such
Tekken 7 has no trouble living up to the
series reputation for tongue-in-cheek
shenanigans and generously gives you
access to the series entire back
catalogue of cutscenes from the very
first Tekken's low-res cutscenes all the
way to background clips made
specifically for Japanese pachinko
machines there's a lot of tech in
history to unlock and browsing the
collection is a wonderful trip down
memory lane what did you just say you
heard me I said this who talks you
expect us to eat this style you mean it
sucks this pepper beef is too damn spice
okay using fight money earned by playing
the games various modes you can purchase
both these cutscenes but also cosmetic
items for characters these include neon
butterfly wings
a floating clownfish companion and
automatic rifles to name a few
well you certainly don't need to dress
up fighters and ridiculous outfits doing
so will give you a new appreciation for
how comfortable Tekken 7 is in its own
skin
on the one hand it's a hardcore and
demanding fighting game but it's also
happy to be the butt of its own jokes
additional items can also be unlocked
rather than purchased within the
treasure battle mode which puts you in a
series of fights with increasing rewards
and challenges there is a training mode
and in arcade mode where you can
practice your moves
but treasure battle is easily the most
attractive way to spend your off time in
Tekken 7 after all if you're going to
practice your moves before hopping
online to fight you might as well have
something cool to show for it presently
a few days after launch Tekken sevens
online modes are experiencing a few
issues across all platforms and while
these are mostly isolated to ranked
matches it's not uncommon to lose
connections and casual matches either
it's an issue that Bandai Namco is aware
of and plans to fix but at the moment
it's not always easy to get into a match
unless you're willing to hammer attempts
for minutes on it notwithstanding that
online play is currently a crapshoot
Tekken 7 remains an easy game to
recommend its diverse roster is packed
with a wide range of personalities and
fighting styles bolstered by a raucous
attitude that begs to be taken seriously
while simultaneously mocking its more
peculiar whims in the process Tekken
fans will find their next favorite
fighting game one that's a product of
decades worth of refinement and while
some of this depth will be lost or out
of reach for newcomers there's enough
fun to be had outside of hardcore
competition to keep players from all
walks of gaming thoroughly entertained
[Music]
you
[Music]